all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
Hummer today will be go over some games
about not losing the Queen in our first
two games we'll show games where you
know the opponent really you know sets
up some nice tactics to win the Queen's
and in the last tier will just show
where you're just flat I'll lose the
Queen okay so so let's check it out okay
so Bensimon our triumphant producer is
playing white in this game against grant
Johnson it's in the double duel day
edition so your player one is white one
is black so he's got the white pieces in
the first encounter with grant Johnson
who we've seen before in some of these
games so okay so white starts out e4 e5
Knight f3 Knight f6 does anybody know
what this opening is called Julian's got
it it's called the Petroff defense so so
white should take and then of course if
black takes right back he is in a lot of
trouble because Queen attacks the knight
and then if you know if he moves the
knight he's got a discovered check where
the Queen's checking so it is Queen's
earlier tacky blacks the knight takes
Bishop takes and White's winning another
variation would be where I attack the
knight and you're like okay I'll just
defend it and then you attack the knight
the knight retreats and same thing
knight c6 check wins the queen so this
is the Petroff defense you've got to be
really good and really booked up in
order to play it it's a decent defense
but just don't fall for the opening
pitfalls so grant doesn't he doesn't
take the pawn he sees the best move d6
so the Knights attack Knight yep go back
to a natural square and now he can take
the
take the pun because now when we play
Queen 2e to hear what moves should black
play because the knight is in a pin so
so moves like f5 Bishop f5 d5 weren't
gonna work because I'll play d3 and then
I'll be up a knight so what's the only
it's the only move black and play here
that doesn't lose the night how can you
break the pin and protect the knight
simultaneously Julian knows go ahead
Julian Queenie seven all right Julian is
really good all right but but then
Simon's like I don't want to even get
involved with any of that stuff so he
plays Bishop c4 aiming at the pivotal f7
square grant he's pretty smart he's like
I want to get castled quick so he's like
Bishop ISA all right so now Ben Simon
plays d3 notice hidden black in his
bishop by playing d3 right away okay cuz
he knows he wants an active Bishop so
it's a good job Ben Simon proud of you
Bishop c4 Bishop e7 now d3 a knight
retreats and now Knights out so black
gets Castle white does the same so so
that's the thing about playing a Petra
is a it's a pretty symmetrical position
here okay so so Knight to c6 activate
the rook okay and now he's going for d5
attacks the Bishop Bishop retreats and
sorry his I had so much fun attacking
the bishop I'm gonna attack the knight
as well all right
makes sense to me 94 notice notice grant
and he's like I'm that I'm not gonna
just trade I just keep activating my
pieces obviously I want to activate my
shop but that's alright rook e8 night e
to g5 night
to g5 so he's like I don't want trade oh
oh
so I grants like darn I probably need to
put my rook back on f8 here oh he could
do the old Knight d5 trick so let's see
let's see what he he decides he decides
to play a very dubious move so sometimes
you just have to cut your losses in
chess okay
like all right I played rook e8 but now
he played my knight to attack I really
needed my rook on f8 it's time to just
say okay
I was joking all right my works back on
that face okay instead he's like I'm
gonna put my King on f8 so it's like is
this a trick it's like there's no way
this is a trick and look I mean you just
flat-out lost your bishop or your rook
the exchange right the exchange instead
of losing two pieces for a rook which
I'm sure Ben Simon would have gone for
he just flat-out loses loses but hey he
didn't have to you know humiliate
himself by playing his work back to f8
so I guess it all worked out for him so
Bishop takes f7 Bishop b4 attacks the
rook alright well here we go here we go
Bishop takes Bishop takes Bishop takes
c6
now he gets a pawn but check King takes
up to get you got a throw on a check I
mean come on come on make it more
complicated nice the g4 check Ben
Simon's like I'm not gonna go up and try
to do any Sunanda because I'll just
retreat back to g1 nice now it's like
I'm taking you ooh
yeah and it's like hmm
it's like I can get a check Saab do it
King g8 and now Knight H to g5 okay now
now after all the fireworks went off to
probably see what's really going on and
just as I suspected
we're up a piece okay so so that's
pretty good
we have we have three pieces he has well
we have three minor pieces he has two
minor pieces we each have a queen and a
rook and then we got one two three four
five pawns he's got and we got six so
not only are we up upon we're up a piece
- so so grant really should have
calculated before you just like I just
trade all these pieces you know so all
right so Queen d6 a fake threat okay
yeah cuz I have fix threats that's all
right I think that's so we're gonna have
our own fake threat Queen e1 not
checkmate because of Queen f8 obviously
so you know what we'll start doing some
fake threat sorry I like it I like it I
like it
Bishop d7 can anybody make a real threat
probably not all right so Knight e4
attack the Queen so nothing else better
do attack the Queen as we'll see he
might win it because in some of these
games we're just gonna flat out when the
Queen for nothing so you never know
Queen the d5 he sees it that was close
one
that was close one all right b3 all
right so he's like my bishops got no
place good to go on this diagonal which
is a lie right I mean Bishop f4 is
almost screaming to be played but that's
fine but so we got a window open already
but welcome hey it is double dual de all
right let's get both the windows open
all right so all right
rook to e8 all right so now tactics
right so now we don't even know maybe
it's been Simon who ends up losing his
his queen so now the knight is in a pin
all right Bishop to b2 so two people
attacking the pawn this is really easy
if you're playing black right c5 right
but then you everybody then it plays
Bishop e3 maybe but at least he's
distracted for a minute
sorry I get it and forget I don't care
you take my pond take it all I don't
care
all right so now we decided to calculate
I guess so
all right so now Queen to g3 all right
so now this is grid notation by Ben
Simon he's just like see so is it c5 I
guess so now he's like all right now
I'll protect my pawn interesting all
right so now he's tells this night to go
away went into this beautiful hole
probably oh but oh you do not want to go
into that beautiful hole you do not want
to go into that beautiful hole and now
do you see and he doesn't even go into
the beautiful he decides to back up but
now remember the name of the game is
don't lose the Queen so it's a 95
unfortunately yeah Kevin's got the the
slammer he's got on the board Knight f6
checked and it's not looking very good
and it is a mop-up time yeah yeah yeah
so obviously you can't take the knight
because it's pinned by the Queen so
Chuck and now grant Johnson you so mad
it's like I'm gonna get a check in just
for the heck of it
that'll show him he'll shop and so now
the Bishop's in a pin so he gets out of
it and so he just wants to pile on work
F one Bishop e6 and now white needs to
be thinking about checkmate but he's
like oh yeah I can just get a fork
whatever rookie seven maybe yeah
r7 yeah Knight takes there's a cake back
because he saw he saw now that if he
takes it's gonna be Shaq
so he don't want to lose the rook so he
just retreats the rook but guess what
it's gonna be checkmate anyway Queen the
g5 check King h7 and obviously you see
Queen to g7 checkmate okay
so it was a good game by Ben you know
grant Johnson he really really messed up
in the beginning he moved their rook off
of the F file
okay the bishop is aiming at f7 you've
moved like obviously you want to play
Bishop g5 here Jim Bishop g4 when you
move the rook off the DF file and now he
brings the knight up you know you just
have to go back whether you want to or
not
okay so now Ben Simon has the black
pieces in this like counter it's a
rematch okay so white starts out d4 d5
c4 even though Ben Simon's been watching
every lecture he's like okay I'll play
east six anyway all the grandmasters
seem to playing in the same field Cup so
he's like alright I guess they override
what I say all right Knight f6 I look
like a grant
he's like I'm playing good I'll get my
Bishop out and then
I'll play e3 all right so he's doing
something right
all right so Knight to d7 and he takes
which is not good cause uh now blacks
Bishop is free all right Queen a for
pens the night
I mean Bishop b5 does this does
essentially the same thing all right
Queen to b6 you can't resist attacking
the Queen
yeah
so this looks like it's gonna be really
tough for him to keep the rook I guess
he has to play Queen well you want me to
play Queen to d1 and then we'll just
repeat the position right I don't want
you to be up apart I already have my
king of the hill before but I actually
it doesn't really matter cuz you're
gonna you're gonna get the you're gonna
get the man anyway so alright so yeah
alright so then you would play Queen to
do you one sorry all right
and then after Queen D one Queen takes
d5 happy alright yeah good he's happy
all right everybody's happy all right
all right so so he takes with the bishop
and he's one step closer to Rockcastle
een here all right I be the d2 he's
still giving them the pawn but instead I
been Sammy is just gonna play play safe
castle all right so now all right no
more mr. nice guy I'm not giving you my
part all right and so now Bensimon
decided to start playing like comer get
a little h6 action again stop any kind
of shenanigans in g5 land all right okay
Bishop to d3 now he goes Knight to g4
why did he do that way do you really
want to take on e3 here we're thinking
about well well because obviously if you
play Knight to g4 you should assume he's
gonna play h3 and put you to the test so
let's see we're you're gonna take with
the knight or the bishop
check
resins for black right yeah all right
it's a good idea okay all right so so
Bensimon wisely plays his knight back to
f6 even though you see unlike grant in
the first game right right you know you
made a mistake and you just you know you
redeemed yourself for it okay so you
didn't you didn't extrapolate all the
nonsense okay so it's a good job good
job good job
all right so Castle now you play Bishop
d6 so after it takes takes he he's get
he's gained control of the C file so
Bensimon she's probably tried to combat
that huh all right I like it
so Knight e5 Knight takes Queen takes
Knight attacks the Queen so we got to be
cognizant of that stuff and alright so
he throws his queen over to the other
side alright so as Julian points out
he's threatening if a random move occurs
takes takes Queen takes Oh obviously
he's too good he's too good and we're in
a lot of trouble alright so let's see if
see if grant figures it out Knight h2 so
so he's got out of the tactic
but so do we think Bensimon should just
go for it anyway probably not because
the night if the night goes up here it
will just get captured he can force a
perpetual check f3 and then there will
be no Queen can come over and block your
only it's just too good some days some
days alright so so let's not sacrifice
all my pieces for no reason okay
let's just get our rook out okay he he
does likewise and now Knight to e4
offering the trade grant puts them to
the test
f3 so are we gonna go into g3 mmm
no he's gonna go to g5 interesting so
he's like all right that fort but that
forest not very good because he just
played f3 to get that night off of efore
right you can just move back - oh yeah
right
unfortunately the pun doesn't that move
back alright so Bishop e2 attacks the
Queen so Queen to g6 yeah now the threat
is back on right Bishop takes h3 as we
saw in the first game with the G pawn in
a pin right so what do you think what do
you think as anybody think
so let's see it's the suspense is
killing me to g4
alright so g4 as we saw in last week's
lectures you know carry on oh you just
kept pushing all his palms in front of
the king and you're like oh some of the
people it was good it was good it was
yeah anyway he ended up getting
checkmated and about time moves after
you started moving all the pieces around
okay so you got to watch out you got to
watch out big time here what would you
do
easy easy easy
Bishop f3 of course I know why right -
King eh what I do I'm not I'm not I'm
not on trial here
grant Johnson's on trial where's great
chance all right it's all right away g4
and of course we attack the pin piece
and we're gonna just crush here all
right Queen to b3 wrens check here Queen
f7 look e to d1 so he's piling on here
and night to g3
attacks the bishop with Chuck hmm
all right so he moves the bishop good
idea
now he's like all right I'm sick of this
I'm taking it and now Bishop takes
grants feeling really good he's got
Bishop Queen King all in a row here
unknown unknown now we were just so
Julian's suggesting a continuation rook
takes c8 rook takes Bishop takes oh oh
oh we got it we got this check coming up
Julian you sure you can resist it so so
Julian found a decent scenario after
rook takes Bishop yeah we'll take the
bishop good yeah yeah and yeah no
worries
wait you sure you don't want to check
them all right
and then white has one two three four
five
well black has one two three four five
but you know we're threatening King f2
here and to eat us stuff so so very
interesting very interesting so instead
he can't wait to take the can't wait to
take on d5 here and so obviously Ben Sam
was gonna black with the Bishop e6
Bishop takes rook takes rook c7 it looks
like King to f2 he did not want to get
checked on a knee to their right so here
it comes yeah yep you called it 94 check
King to e1 he gets his king central is
here so Queen to d5 here Knight attacks
it he defends it all right so notice
Queen Knight Queen all in the same same
line here so and you just let the get
Czechia here it takes III check King f2
that is easier you got it 94 chunk and
once again he's lost his queen but at
least this time he can you can at least
get something for it he decided he's
gonna take the rook this time around
oh right well yeah well yeah as your
land points out hey don't get a go don't
go somewhere where than I can check you
good and and so now it's a mop-up time
for Bensimon let's see if he can he can
figure it out quickly
Rick D for attacks the night rookie 8
going for another discovery he steps out
alright check just kill the pin King f2
rookie for offering the trade he always
takes the trade Knight takes check King
up more checks came to e3 Queen efore
yeah Queen Queen should just take up for
here King II won
yeah so you're gonna get it all now
Queen 6 check take speed 2 and now you
get that
you didn't you didn't take the night I
mean I mean it's obvious right and then
yeah I mean eventually eventually it
goes on to checkmate so so once again
they fell for the same tactic so those
are that's hard work you know you have
to you set up those discoveries in these
games coming up there's just going to be
it's just gonna be attacked the Queen
when the Queen you know so our hero then
unfortunate losses is playing black so
we'll flip the board so so let's see how
this is hissing USA open black all right
he is the hero after all even though
even though your hero sometimes you
don't win but that's okay
but yeah you're here to get better so
let's check it out so d4 d5 and then
I've never really seen this move F
forward before this don't reverse
Stonewall it's just it's just the
flat-out Stonewall yeah so I don't know
about that opening so II six all right
so so g4 so
alright so in this position 94 and does
everybody know what this is a
threatening here fools mate correct
Queen
checkmate which would be stopped by
Knight f3
so Knight up so Bishop Bishop e7 yes yes
and then H for height H you're gonna get
checkmate one way or the other
all right instead of Knight e4 here the
move g6 was played and so he attacks the
night here forcing it to go to e4 Bishop
attacks the knight doesn't care
Bishop g7 takes takes Knight c3 attacks
the pawn so right we need to take the
pawn right free pawn just take it right
it looks good to me
instead he gets a third man on the on
the job yeah he takes and now we get the
night taking it c3
I don't think you saw blacks follow up
here though Julian my check and a check
unfortunately he can just take so Castle
Knight f3 tries to get the bishop out
castles Bishop c6 attacks the night its
defended by the Queen any questions in
the back so in this position instead of
castling but you want to just play
Bishop d2 and then Castle queenside are
just not even Castle at all well I'll
play Bishop c6 preventing you from cast
94 well you're already up a whole piece
for white so it's like you do whatever
you want really and if you just content
on castling they're probably just castle
all right yeah
the man daggers here all right so Knight
attacks the bishop takes takes and now
f5 is played so it yeah so hopefully
everybody knows about um % where if your
opponent's pawn is on the 5th rank for
the white pieces and you play it up -
meaning that's also on the fifth rank
you can on the next move you can take it
just this one yeah he decided to play
the check
so um Poseidon crewed up occurred here
like that should have occurred obviously
but instead played the big check
most likely King g7 rook attacks the
Queen Queen up a three so we get a big
check here he blacks with the bishop so
so so he went from plus a hundred with
Queen takes so if you go there it's
automatically mate and if you go here
doesn't matter you want you want to be
precise right then at the way I'm
fortunate a nice covering at4 so so it's
a heck of a comeback that's for sure so
Richard was right we should prize should
enough Castle kingside in here yeah III
much better okay
so unfortunately in the game Bishop III
ended up being a stellar move cuz black
decides to try his own version of the
checkmate
aiming at g2 yeah in case anybody wants
to know we have a grandmaster Ken West
in the audience tonight and he's
reflecting that I cannot believe this is
not one of his games so of course
instead of taking what the knight takes
with the rook and
well you always want to take the bishop
all right so that was one game where you
know he really didn't have to work too
hard to win the Queen in fact we put a
piece that was hanging to attack it so
not very good so in this game our hero
is the the white pieces and so he's
gonna copy off of his opponent here it
just so happened your opponent played
the same thing very interesting all
right
so Bishop g4 attacks the night so okay
so good thing we have our good friend
Julian in the audience here knight
Knight to e5 is is the best move yeah
yeah it's okay sorry falling three moves
we can just take take the bishop for
free right never double the pawns so
white brings out his knight and black
wasn't bluffing so he takes eat takes
and East six Bishop d3 is played Bishop
before it pins the knight so so right
you don't want a it's been fine golden
notes you know when I'm going to be
playing Bishop d2 it's too weak so you
Castle here and then takes it takes but
you can always you can always undo if
you're really concerned about these
pawns you can always undo them by
eventually playing you know c4 f5 or
so if the game purchases Bishop d2
knight c6
now he gets castled and now he loses a
pawn gnome attacks attacks tonight he's
back
Bishop the b5 so in this position the
knight is stuck it's a stuck piece it
can't move it's pinned there's it's not
moving anywhere
but after castle he's no longer in up
him okay so you always have to be aware
of that stuff so in this position he
decides to attack the bishop and
unfortunately bye-bye Queen so it was a
pretty move so hopeful so sometimes you
don't have to be a master of tactics to
win a queen sometimes it just happens if
you're if you look hard enough for it
okay